it might be a little late to get in on
the Bitcoin bubble but it's not too late
to start building apps for people that
use crypto currencies in this episode
I'm going to show you how to use coin
base as a custom authentication provider
for firebase that means your users will
be able to log in to firebase via
coinbase and then you can use the coin
base API to handle Bitcoin transactions
if you're new here make sure to
subscribe and you can follow along with
the source code at angular firebase com
let's first take a look at how this is
going to work the user is going to click
the log in with coinbase button in our
angular app that redirects then the coin
base where they authenticate into their
account then coinbase redirects them
back to angular with an encrypted off
code the code then goes to a cloud
function which exchanges it for an
actual access token and refresh token
from coinbase we can then mint our own
custom firebase authentication token
then send it back to angular and log the
user in as a firebase user learning this
process will also allow you to
authenticate with other providers such
as Instagram Twitter pata Phi and many
others to get started you'll need a coin
base account and you'll want to create a
new o2 application make note of your API
keys and then make sure you set a
redirect URI that points to localhost
4200 slash redirect after that you can
create a brand new angular 5 app and
make sure it has the routing module from
there you'll need to install angularfire
2 and firebase so make sure to follow
the official instructions at the
angularfire repo now inside of our
angular project we're going to
initialize cloud functions we're also
going to use the new typescript option
so make sure your firebase CLI tools are
updated to the latest version I also
have a few dependencies in the cloud
function environment the main one is
Axios which replaces the node HTTP
module the reason we do that is because
promises are a lot easier to work with
and callbacks when dealing with
asynchronous activity and a cloud
function then I also have cores and
crypto which we'll see in use here in
just a second because we're going to be
minting custom off tokens we need to use
our actual service account from firebase
it's just a JSON file and I'll quickly
show you in firebase where you can find
it go to project settings then service
account and then download a new private
key for nodejs then you can go ahead and
save it inside the functions directory
this file
contain sensitive API keys so make sure
not to expose them in your front-end
code or any kind of public git
repository after that we'll go ahead and
import our dependencies and then
initialize cores with origin true I'm
only testing these functions locally so
for right now I'm setting the redirect
URI to localhost 4200 slash redirect I'm
also setting variables for the coinbase
api keys and make sure you follow these
variable names because they're going to
be reformatted as query parameters later
on because they're going to be reused
frequently I'm setting them as a default
params object here now we're ready to
write the first actual cloud function
which is called redirect the only thing
it needs to do is properly format at URL
and then redirect the user to that point
so they can't authenticate into their
coinbase account a useful trick is to
put all of these parameters in an object
and then use query string stringify to
add them to the URL it'll make your code
a lot more readable and maintainable the
scope parameter is the interesting one
that'll tell us the permission level
that we have on the user's account which
in this case will be able to read that
users wallet and you can get additional
details on each of these parameters from
the coinbase Docs so now we're gonna
switch gears into angular and we'll see
how we can trigger this redirect URL
first I'm going to generate a component
for the user details then I'll generate
another to handle the auth redirect and
I'll generate a service so we can share
some functionality between components
let's go ahead and start in the auth
service where we import angularfire auth
then in the constructor we will observe
the auth state from firebase so the user
observable is the current user from
firebase what I do next here is
considered a bad practice and angular
but I'm doing it to keep this demo
simple I'm opening a pop-up window that
points to our redirect cloud function
the proper way to do this is to wrap the
window in its own service so you can use
it in non browser environments such as
on the server or in a mobile app there's
still a lot of code to get through so
I'm just going to cheat a little bit on
this one so that's going to open the
pop-up and then once we actually have
the minted token from firebase we're
going to call sign in with custom token
from angular
this method just allows you to sign in
with your own custom minted token and
once signed in we'll just go ahead and
cheat again and call window close to
close the pop-up before we jump into the
components I'm going to go into the app
routing module and you can see we have
the user details component on the route
path and then we have the auth redirect
component at the redirect path that path
should match the redirect URI you set up
in coinbase
then we'll jump over to the user details
component and right now all this needs
to do is inject the auth service and
then we'll unwrap that user observable
in the HTML later on we'll get the
user's Bitcoin wallet but for now we're
not going to worry about that and the
HTML we can unwrap the user observable
and if it's not defined we'll give the
user a button to login with coinbase
now let's go ahead and run our cloud
functions by running npm run serve from
the functions directory that should tell
you that cloud functions are being
emulated on port 5,000 then if we go
into angular and click login with
coinbase it brings up this pop-up and
redirects us to our coinbase account
it requires the user to sign in with
two-factor authentication so it'll send
them a text message that they didn't
have to verify inside this form after
they log in to the firebase account then
they can click authorize and that
redirects us back to our angular app
inside this pop-up at this point nothing
happens because we still need to mint
our authentication token and create the
user in firebase we're going to do that
by going back to indexed es inside of
our cloud functions directory we're
going to wrap the request response
inside of cores and then we're going to
return a promise from the function
called mint auth token and that's just
going to return our custom token in JSON
format so that looks nice and simple but
there's actually a lot more to it
instead of writing a big long promise
chain I'm going to use an asynchronous
helper function so we do that by using
the async keyword followed by the
function mint auth token and it's going
to take the request as an argument if
you're not familiar with async await
it's nothing more than syntactic sugar
for promises our async function returns
a promise itself and it does that by
awaiting a bunch of other promises
inside of itself it results in way
better code readability when you need to
share values at different
in the promise chain the first thing we
need to do is hit the coin base API for
the access token and refresh token we
can do that by defining our query
parameters just like we did in the
previous function then set that as the
endpoint variable then this login
variable notice it awaits a post request
to this endpoint the value of the login
variable is going to be the response
from this endpoint which should be the
coin base access token and refresh token
well it's really cool is we can just
treat them like normal variables even
though it's an asynchronous operation
that would normally require us to call
then once we have an access token from
home base we can make API calls on the
user's behalf so the first thing we're
going to do is get their user profile by
calling this get coin base user method
that we're going to define next then
that's also going to be a response of
some data including the users coin base
user ID now that we have that we can
actually mint our own custom firebase
auth token so we call admin auth create
custom token with the coin base user ID
then one last thing we're going to do is
save the coin base access token and
refresh token in firebase and I want to
point out that it's really important
that you have good security rules on
these they should really only be
accessed by the admin on a back-end
server then we can just have this
function return the auth token so in
other words it's going to return a
promise of the auth token string now
that we have this access token from
coinbase we can start making calls to
the API I went ahead and extracted this
into its own function because it's
probably something that you'll want to
reuse it makes a get request to coinbase
and the important part here is in this
request we need to have an authorization
header that's formatted in a very
specific way it should say authorization
with bearer and then the actual access
token after it so that's all there is to
it for the cloud function part now we
need to go back to angular and fill out
our redirect component again this is the
component that lives in that pop-up
window that coinbase redirects to after
the user signs in on their coinbase
account coinbase sends back the auth
code in the query parameters so we're
going to use activated route to retrieve
it and we'll also bring in our off
service and the HTTP client from angular
during ng on an it will get the actual
query parameter code
from the URL sent back to us from
coinbase then we can use it to make a
request to our cloud function endpoint
and mint the actual auth token if the
code is defined then we'll point to
localhost 5000 and we'll make a post
request to that endpoint and with the
response we get back which is going to
be that custom auth token we can then
use it to call custom sign in from our
off service which will authenticate the
user then make sure to subscribe to send
the request let's go back to angular and
try out our login button again this time
we go to coinbase as expected and then
authorize and now it's calling the cloud
function and minting that token after a
second or two it closes and we're logged
in to firebase with our custom user ID
you can verify the user is created by
going into your authentication tab in
firebase and you should see your custom
user in there then you'll also want to
go into the real time database and make
sure the access token and refresh token
are saved under that user ID and again
make sure you have these lock down and
your back-end database rules I'm going
to go head and wrap up the video here
but in the next video I'm going to show
you how to use these access and refresh
tokens to make requests to the coinbase
api you'll be able to send and receive
Bitcoin payments as well as see the
balance and users wallet and it opens
the door for all kinds of different
creative cryptocurrency features that's
it for coinbase both with firebase if
this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you're serious about
building apps with the stack consider
becoming a pro subscriber at angular
firebase com you'll get a free copy of
my book as well as one on one project
support and a whole bunch of other
exclusive content thanks for watching
and I'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]